[Musique]
ils
viennent en Chine sur un samake de brevet viennent un kilo Maha
briller chérie un siège maintenant arrive grange je
parle de Lake Lee 300 salsa de tomate
environ - un pub ou un propriétaire de bar pour décider
est-ce qu'un goanna
vraiment cool cool ouais  Sabrina tu étais
un Maki à propos d'Atacama Nakula a le
potentiel d'aller en charter
[Musique]
les pêcheurs sourient vraiment maintenant
au cou Ratio du lac Victoria parce que nous
recevons, nous recevons plus de
visiteurs en ce moment quand vous voyez ces
autres gars vraiment bondés avec  beaucoup d'
habitants de Kazuma viennent acheter la
première phase parce que les gens craignent ceux dont ils ont
besoin d'une boîte chinoise la phase de la boîte
à cause du coronavirus
[Musique]
avec l'éclat du coronavirus
ces gens qui vendent du poisson en Chine
ont un certain désavantage  parce
qu'en ce moment ils sont incapables de faire
leur affaire et moi en tant que
vendeur ils vont manger du poisson maintenant mais l'
avantage de vendre du poisson au prix que je
veux
[Musique] [
Musique]
ils peuvent apporter le fonctionnaire
parce que j'ai eu ce sentiment, ce qui signifie que
si à l'avenir je ne peux pas obtenir de poisson
de l'extérieur, il restera un
espace vide mais censé être comblé et
maintenant nous aurons une certaine pénurie
parce qu'ils n'obtiennent pas  assez de poisson
alors cela est susceptible d'affecter les prix
[Musique]